este es el salvador el 16 de noviembre
de 1989 poco después de las 7 de la
mañana
unos cuarenta hombres fuertemente
armados muchos de ellos vestidos con
uniforme militar habían llegado sobre
las cuatro de la madrugada y durante 35
minutos dispararon diversos tipos de
armas entre ellas el m16 tan famoso por
la guerra de vietnam
sobre las cuatro y media de la madrugada
se marcharon
y dejaron como ven ahí en el césped del
la vivienda que ocupaban unos jesuitas
españoles y dos personas que trabajaban
para ellos dos mujeres una madre y una
hija dejaron ocho cadáveres en total
cuatro de ellos en el césped los otros
cuatro estaban dos jesuitas más en unos
las celdas dormitorio que tenían en el
interior de la casa y la cocinera la
asistenta que les atendía y su hija en
otro en otro cuarto
uno de ellos
si no me equivoco se este que está en
primer plano era el padre ignacio
ellacuría que era uno de los grandes
pensadores de la teología de la
liberación en aquellos momentos en los
que las dictaduras militares entre otras
es brasil y ayer donde surgió en buena
parte ese movimiento
cristiano
era mundialmente conocido precisamente
por sus aportaciones a la teología de la
liberación y era al mismo tiempo el
rector de la universidad centroamericana
la uca donde fueron acribillados
poco después de los hechos
en el cuartel del primer batallón de
infantería un soldado de los asesinos
gritó ya han huido ya han caído
ellacuría y baró vamos a por más
comunistas
en el pequeño país centroamericano del
salvador que en esa época tenía poco más
de 6 millones de habitantes gobernaba
entonces un partido de ultraderecha de
esos que ahora se están poniendo de moda
y los llamados escuadrones de la muerte
que estaban al mando quizás los más
mayores los recuerden de un mayor que se
llamaba roberto d'aubuisson sembraban
eran el brazo armado de ese gobierno y
podía van tanto a los jesuitas que el
mando militar ordenó asesinar los el
frente de liberación
martí de liberación nacional fmln que
era la guerrilla izquierdista que había
surgido igual que en otros países de
américa latina tras la revolución cubana
había decretado había promovido una
llamada por ellos ofensiva final la
capital del salvador estaba
prácticamente sitiada por la guerrilla y
los barrios más populares estaban
ocupados
yo llegué a ese lugar
aproximadamente a las siete y media de
la mañana cuando los cadáveres todavía
no habían sido como en lo habitual
cubiertos por una sábana hay fotografías
donde ya no se les ve de una forma tan
dramática me había avisado un colega
salvadoreño y acudía allí porque ya
había terminado el toque de queda
yo sabía que entre los fallecidos estaba
el padre ellacuría que además de lo que
he dicho antes era buen amigo mío porque
era la fuente principal que teníamos los
periodistas españoles media docena que
entonces trabajábamos por aquella zona
había muy poca policía en aquellos
momentos tan poca que como ven ahí el
lugar tal como se ve en las películas y
en la vida real no estaba acordonada la
zona del crimen en el suelo había
docenas centenares diría yo de
casquillos de bala y yo cometí quizá la
torpeza pensando que había suficientes
pruebas de [ __ ] algunos que he traído
esta tarde
bueno está la primera crónica que mande
ese día
que ahora les contaré cómo sucedió y
esta fotografía querría remarcar la no
sé si se ve bien porque es blanco y
negro está hecha por un amigo mío y
colega que trabajaba conmigo en aquel
momento gervasio sánchez le habrán oído
es uno de los grandes fotos periodistas
que hay en españa y aquí ya sobre un
guerrillero muerto el soldado está
apuñalando varias veces yo no estaba
presente me lo contó gervasio estaba en
otro lugar y le apoyó los varias veces y
no contento con eso perdón me salta una
o es que ha desaparecido
bueno hay una foto más en donde le está
cortando las orejas al cadáver estas son
las balas como les dije que las tengo en
mi casa desde hace ya los esos 30 años
para recuerdo de aquel día tan dramático
la aventura trágica que yo viví ese día
me costó aparte de como me ha recordado
mi mujer
ponerme a llorar durante un largo rato
en el cuarto de baño del hotel antes de
empezar a escribir la crónica me costó
muchísimo esfuerzo y casi estuve a punto
de no poder conseguir el objetivo mío y
de mi periódico que me había mandado
allí invirtiendo una cantidad enorme
considerable y era además de escribir
qué es lo que para eso nos pagan a los
periodistas conseguir mandar la crónica
y ese es el objetivo de que yo esté aquí
hoy
no para relatar mis aventuras
profesionales o mi trabajo profesional
sino para ver como el periodismo ha
cambiado dramáticamente desde esa fecha
hasta hoy
la principal tarea que tenía un
corresponsal un enviado especial en
estos en estos sitios general en
cualquier parte del mundo recuerdo que
era el año 89 era transmitir las
crónicas sobre todo si se estaba en un
país poco desarrollado y las líneas
telefónicas eran malas no existía
existía internet pero no existían los
modernos sistemas de transmisión de
ahora ni muchísimo menos
y había que
recurrir a la vieja
técnica de mandar un télex un fax si lo
sabía en el salvador no había en ese
momento y si lo sabía estaban totalmente
inaccesible porque la guerrilla ocupaba
media media ciudad y el sistema era
llamar por teléfono y dictar la crónica
entonces los periódicos tenían un
departamento de secretarias que cogían
las crónicas por teléfono los más
veteranos recordarán que los periódicos
de la época ponían crónicas de nuestro
enviado especial transmitida por tele o
transmitida por teléfono que era una
cosa absolutamente ridícula a decirlo
pero bueno se era era la costumbre y al
mismo tiempo que me puse a escribir en
el hotel pedí la línea la línea
telefónica para poder hablar al
periódico al día 16 que con el que
trabajaba entonces yo sabía que iba a
tardar dos o tres horas lo que no sabías
que podía llegar hasta 6 y se acercaba
lo que llaman en periodismo el deadline
o la hora del cierre decir si tardaba un
poco más no podía transmitir y en todo
el día y todo el esfuerzo y todo el
drama que había vivido era inútil
y dice lo que había hecho en otras
ocasiones bajar a la sala donde estaban
las telefonistas y darle a una de ellas
discretamente un billete de 100 dólares
que era el equivalente pues a lo que
ella ganaba en un mes aproximadamente
con seguir la línea pase la crónica al
periódico y otros colegas míos entre
otros recuerdos al del país no pudo
hacer lo mismo porque sencillamente no
se podía hacer
nueve años después este libro que edite
que publiqué escribí y publiqué en
colaboración con natalia bolívar que es
una antropóloga
cubana tiene 6 560 páginas y nos
estuvimos enviando mensajes por internet
porque ya funcionaba año 1998 y en pocos
minutos
yo veía milagrosamente creía que en
algún momento aquello se iba a
interrumpir que se pasaba un libro
entero se pasaban docenas de fotografías
nos pasábamos pruebas y correcciones y
no pasaba nada el país el vamos el mundo
estaba a punto ya ya estaba
prácticamente
en funcionamiento a sentir una gran
transformación en lo que es el mundo de
la información
antes de eso les voy a pasar brevemente
porque creo que muchos de ustedes no los
conocen sobre todo la gente más joven
que hay aquí como eran los periódicos
antes los periódicos en la época que yo
empecé a trabajar en ellos las
redacciones eran así esta es la
redacción del new york times'
aproximadamente deben ser los años 70
como ven viejas máquinas de escribir una
de ellas muy parecidas la tengo yo en
casa una underwood que compré allí en
eeuu en un saldo
y bueno imagínense una sala aquí se ve
parcialmente en donde había más de 100
personas escribiendo a máquina aquello
era un ruido verdaderamente infernal y
los periodistas estaban acostumbrados a
trabajar con ese ruido y probablemente
con una botella de whisky en el cajón de
la mesa hoy se tienen cocacola si no sé
qué mejor beber si coca-cola o whisky
esta es la primera redacción del país
como ven también parece una oficina
normal donde ya aparecen unos primeros
pantallas que es un sistema que se
diseñó exclusivamente para el país
cuando cuando nació que era lentísimo
con una pantalla verde no se podía
considerar todavía un ordenador era una
especie de máquina de escribir con una
pantalla de plasma vamos o de lo que sea
que el material les señaló aquí la chica
está que está en el centro algunas la
recordarán en mariló ruiz elvira que
cuya familia de aquí de manzanares y que
tenían una ferretería en la en la calle
empedrada no sé si algunos lo recuerdan
donde hoy está viaje marsans
esta otra fotografía
es en los momentos previos a la salida
del diario 16 que fue el competidor del
diario del país y cuya batalla perdimos
en el año 1976 yo alguna vez era joven
también y tenía corbata también ahí en
el centro
sentada en una mesa con una chaqueta
clara no creo que fuera blanca porque
manchó mucho y una corbata ese será yo
entonces esto eran las redacciones de
los periódicos como ven no hay ningún
ordenador allí al fondo a la izquierda
se ve una máquina de escribir con
carritos que era lo que se acostumbraba
a trabajar entonces
de ahí salían las noticias iban a seguir
en un proceso que voy a pasar muy me han
dicho que había un reloj por algún sitio
vale entonces voy a acelerar un poco
el proceso que se seguía para producir
un periódico es absolutamente distinto
al de ahora y no hace tanto tiempo hace
30 años 40 años que se hacían así esta
portada del new york times' me la dieron
en un momento en que una visita que
hicimos a eeuu un grupo de periodistas
me invitaron a asistir allí te pedían la
documentación a la entrada ya la salida
te regalaban la portada del día en que
tú habían nacido que es el 18 de marzo
de 1945 donde ven todo está lleno de
de texto de plomo y resulta
efectivamente es una página plomiza
porque está hecha a base de como verán
ahora las noticias fundamentalmente son
están relacionadas con la la casi
inminente terminación de la segunda
guerra mundial este es el primer
periódico en el que yo trabajé como ven
el diseño es prácticamente igual y
casualmente es elegido esta portada
porque es el día en que el gobierno de
la dictadura franquista ordenó el cierre
y por tanto nos quedamos todos todos sin
trabajo pero en fin yo llegué a este
periódico armado con bueno aquí ven el
que algunos los reconocerán la voladura
del periódico que no fue provocada por
el régimen sino la empresa como estaba
en la ruina vendió el periódico y ahí se
construye un grupo de unas viviendas
yo llegué allí se me preguntó qué podía
hacer le dije que de todo porque
entonces los periodistas
en los periodistas eran éramos un poco
todo logos y me dijeron que si sabía
confeccionar que camps que es cómo se
llamaba entonces a los periódicos y dije
por supuesto que sí claro no tenía ni
idea entonces armado con este arte
confeccionar ahora se llama diseñar un
concepto que es el mismo pero entonces
tenía otra otra denominación este es un
tipo metro
que es muy antiguo y con esto uno se
sentaba a la mesa cogía una maqueta en
blanco y diseñaba colocaba las fotos y
los textos que fueran de una manera más
atractiva que lo que se le se mostraba
éste ya es un poco más moderno y más
caro porque era del diario 'el país' si
tenían más más dinero para producirlos
entonces el proceso que se seguía las
noticias llegaban a parte de por los
redactores propios por los los teletipos
esta es una sala de teletipos que es un
artefacto enorme imaginaos que ahora las
noticias que llegan por un móvil y
recibir centenares si queréis al día al
se transmitían las noticias normalmente
se tardaba en un folio o unos diez
minutos en recibirlos había trabajadores
que se ocupaban sólo de cortar el
teletipo y según la sección de que eran
ponían al comienzo si era política
nacional e internacional sucesos y se la
distribuía a los periodistas este es un
crimen que había en esa época en muchas
redacciones de los periódicos de españa
donde uno marcaba la línea y transmitían
una cinta perforada eso se veía entonces
en la época en telégrafos
voy a pasar rápidamente cuál era el
proceso en las noticias llegaban al
taller del periódico está la sala de
linotipias ahí se componía se escribía
es como una máquina de escribir pero en
vez de sacar papel lo que sacaban eran
imaginaos como era una línea de estas
que uno bajaba al taller del diario
madrid que era pequeña había ocho o diez
funcionando y era un ruido ensordecedor
cómo se ven esas son columnas de plomo
que son como salía de la linotipia estos
son cajistas aquí se iban cogiendo las
letras para componer los títulos allí ya
son las planchas que se iban haciendo
figuras de cuatro en cuatro
esta es una visión panorámica creo que
es de un periódico alemán pero más o
menos todos los talleres de los
periódicos
eran así daban ocupación a centenares de
personas el primer taller del diario 16
siendo un periódico mediano era de unas
200 personas y ésta ya era la rotativa
que era el punto final de aquí salía el
periódico y llegaba a los quioscos este
es un tiempo que todavía sobrevive y
está en la calle serrano
de aquí voy a retroceder un momento
porque qué está pasando ahora y qué
pasaba cuando yo empecé a transmitir
este es el primer mini ordenador que yo
tuve que epson como ven allí tiene una
pantallita que tiene creo que son cuatro
o cinco líneas nada más he hecho el
cálculo de las de los píxeles que tenía
en el ordenador este y eran 120 x 30 lo
cual da un total de 3 mil 600 píxeles lo
que tenía esa pequeña pantalla como ven
aquí a la derecha hay una micro casete
por donde como la memoria era tan corta
si escribía es un folio folio y medio
dos folios se llenaba la memoria tenías
que parar copiarla a la casete y borrar
todo lo que habías escrito y volver a
empezar así la crónica era más larga no
total que las el proceso era lentísimo
la crónica esa una vez que la tenías
escrita la tenías que transmitir yo el
otro día cuando le comentaba manuel de
lo que iba a hablar le hablé de este
artefacto esto se llamaba
de orejeras también una copiadora
acústico es un hombre completo yo
llevaba a uno de estos cuando salía de
viaje y la maleta que portaba en esos
momentos pesaba aproximadamente 20 kilos
entre el ordenador que era mucho más
pesado que lo ahora el transmisor y todo
este tipo de cosas más cables para
desenchufar de las de las habitaciones
del hotel y poder conectar porque había
diferentes conexiones a la línea
telefónica para poder transmitir bueno
que lo que ha pasado ahora todo esto ha
pasado la historia la redacción es estar
del país actual están llenas de
pantallas esta es la de new york times'
recordar la primera
y esto ya es otro mundo aquí ha llegado
al mundo de internet de pleno y
arrasando el periodismo se ha modificado
espectacularmente las noticias si antes
se llegaban unas 500 600 noticias al día
y una redacción de 30 40 50 redactores
tenía que seleccionar lo más importante
del día ahora son miles y es imposible
comprobar todas y cada una de ellas